with baseball season in the off season
or baseball in the off season until the
spring the las vegas ballpark has been
transformed into a dazzling winter
wonderland it's opening night for the
new attraction it's called enchant
christmas wow what a spectacular scene
an array of lights can't wait hector
mejia is there reporting live for us
this morning in summerlin to show us
around hector i'm just amazed at what
they offer i mean there's ice skating
what else is there
[Music]
they also have vendors in fact they have
just about roughly 30 vendors most of
them are local so there's also a
shopping experience and also for those
couples out there
drop what you're doing and take a look
at this this is an area where maybe you
can come out here with a ring pop a
question and joining us i have jordan
with enchant to talk to us about this
installation and just the overall
experience good morning sir good morning
yeah so as you enter the ballpark and as
you come down into the experience while
your goal is to find the nine lost
reindeer and help save christmas we do
make it very difficult to find them so
you'll happen upon moments like this
so we have these photo moments where you
can share a special a special photo with
the person you love
and those people that mean so much to
you and this is one that's very fond of
for young couples at our event and you
re telling me in fact a lot of the
people who come out to the enchant
installations or the attraction a lot of
them are couples yeah date nights is
actually our biggest demographic though
it is a family-friendly event for kids
and adults of all ages but we do have a
lot of folks hanging out for date nights
and tonight is opening night you guys
are expecting a lot of people can you
talk to us about the crowd control
efforts most definitely yeah we're
almost sold out for tonight and how we
handle our crowd control is we ensure
that we have only a certain amount per
arrival time window so that ensures that
we have lower lines we don't have
crowding and it allows people to have a
really enjoyable experience without
having 12 000 people at one time in one
place you were telling me you guys were
doing the preset times time windows
before it was cool yeah back you know in
2016 when we first started our event we
started doing that and we just found it
was a really great customer experience
to be able to come and to be able to
stay as long as you want but that
arrival window restricts the amount of
people that come so it's not overcrowded
it's fantastic so first time here in las
vegas and you know many would be
wondering why the ballpark tell us why
well one this is an amazing amazing
facility it's nicer than some of our
major league baseball parks and so we
thought it was an incredible place to
showcase our event also it's las vegas
there's so many people here that live
and work in las vegas and we wanted to
create an event for them in a place that
was accessible with free parking that
was just an amazing place for their
family memories fantastic thank you for
your time so uh still ahead of the next
half hour we're changing locations we're
talking with the vendor in case you need
to do some black friday shopping today
before i let you guys go i want to show
this beautiful tree large large tree
here and it's uh more spectacular in
person the uh pictures already look
amazing this looks so much better in
person reporting live hector mejia live
local now back to oh it's bound to it
just sparkles on camera hector that is
just amazing that whole ring sure does
the engagement ring area that's uh just
took my breath away it is beautiful it's
got to be what at least 200 carats
right the ring itself let's just say 500
cannons let's just go ahead and say 500
and you know for all those couples
coming out here
no pressure no pressure right it better
be a good ring better be a nice ring
right even if you're single no pressure
all right well okay hector my answer is
yes i do i do it's nice it's beautiful
thank you
and and the the timed events making
reservations heather that was they made
it cool before everybody got in the
groove with the pandemics that was
really smart of them because nobody
wants to try to stuff into a holiday
event like that
more holiday events happening the
fremont street experience commemorating
the jewish holiday hanukkah with grand
menorah lighting it's happening sunday
at 4 30. it'll be lit and on display
throughout hanukkah and you can find
more information and tons of events we
have everything that is happening here
in town posted on our website
8newsnow.com